one of the biggest questions and what
some people call possibly the biggest
plot hole of Avengers infinity war is if
Thanos wanted to balance the universe
and save it why didn't he just double
all of the resources for somebody who
preaches mercy to the universe it
certainly does seem like the more
merciful option would be to just double
the resources instead of killing
everybody so is there a rhyme or reason
to fan o's choosing random mass genocide
over doubling the universe's resources
how's it going everyone it's Warren and
according to the directors and
screenwriters of Avengers infinity war
and Avengers in game there is directors
Joe into Anthony Russo and screenwriters
Christopher Markus and Stephen McFeely
have laid in to give us some insight on
this question and I'll break it all down
for you in this video but quick reminder
I started a new giveaway giving away
five imax tickets if you'd like to enter
for your chance to win all you have to
do is be subscribed to my channel like
this video and comment down below with
your thoughts and your favorite
superhero or villain it certainly was an
interesting idea
Thanos foresaw the universe dying so he
set out to save it by killing half of it
but it might be really good Wow
this plan doesn't really make much sense
to us but according to the directors and
the writers it makes perfect sense to
Thanos in the commentary for Avengers
infinity war we got an explanation as to
why fan o's didn't double the resources
and the infinity war scene on nowhere
the filmmakers went through some of the
underlying drives and emotions in Thanos
and they said that the events on Titan
are part of Thanos's reasoning but his
character flaws are what really drive
him Anthony Russo said during the
commentary people have asked us why fans
didn't just used the stones to double
the resources in the universe and
clearly he is not interested
screenwriter stephen mcfeely then added
no it's about free will that doesn't
solve the problem we're just going to
get there millions of years from now
this is an opportunity for people to get
it right he trusts them you know and
then director Joe Russo added well he
was told no to an idea that he had that
he felt was the only solution and then
was proved right to himself when that
solution was not acted upon
so his messianic complex he is now
committed to following through on the
idea he had men
many years ago he is not a stable
although he appears stable at times he
is not a stable individual so basically
what McFeely said is Santos doesn't feel
like doubling the resources will
actually solve the problem it's just
temporarily fixing it but eventually the
universe will end up in the same place
on the brink of extinction but what
director Joe Russo said is really wife a
knows decided that random mass genocide
would be better than doubling the
resources and that is Thanos was facing
this problem with his home planet Titan
he presented his idea of random mass
genocide and they said no even though he
knew it would work so the people of
Titan went about their own plan which
was most likely cutting back on
resources and trying to get more
resources whether that would be planting
seeds or breeding more animals whatever
it may be but the people of Titan knew
what the problem was there was not
enough resources so they went about
their own plan and Thanos had to watch
his home planet die knowing that if they
would have listened to him the planet
would still be alive and half of the
population would still be alive and half
of the people being alive still is
better than nobody being alive so this
goes back to what McFeely said Thanos
knows firsthand that it won't work
doubling the resources won't work and
then you go back to what Joe Russo said
where he says thinness is not a stable
individual he watched his planet die
knowing that his plan would have worked
so he's committed to his plan and thinks
it's the only way that he could save the
universe a combination of all these
reasons as wife a knows decided that
eliminating half of the universe was the
only way to save it instead of doubling
its resources and this is coming
directly from the writers and the
directors of Avengers infinity war so
these are the reasons so let me know
what you think about what the writers
and the director said about why phantos
didn't double the resources and why he
was committed to the snap let me know
your thoughts in the comments down below
and again don't forget to subscribe
comment and like the video so you can
enter the giveaway and stay up to date
on everything relating to Marvel and
Avengers endgame as always thank you all
so much for watching woof woof
[Music]
you